[موسيقى]
شوارع تزينها الفرحه وموائد تحتضن البيوت
هنا تحلو ليالي رمضان
هنا مصر
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
مكانه خاصه يحظى بها الشهر الفضيل في قلوب
المصريين بزغت معها عادات ومعان جعلته
مختلفا عن سائر بلدان المعموره
فوانيس رمضان في واحده من اقدم هذه
العادات التي تعود الى ما يزيد على الف
عام يمكن القول انها من عمر القاهره حيث
تؤكد الروايات التاريخيه ان الخليفه
الفاطمي المعز لدين الله امر باضاءه
المساجد بها طوال شهر رمضان حتى اصبحت
طقسا شعبيه يعبر عن الفرحه بالشهر الكريم
[موسيقى]
شيئا فشيئا تطور شكل الفانوس من الخشب الى
النحاس ومنه الى الزجاج المصقول واصبحت
صناعته فنا زحف الى دول الجوار ليجمع بين
اصله كاداه اناره للمساجد والمنازل وبين
معناه كعنصر احتفالي وزخرفي اما زينه
رمضان فهي طقس اخر يميز شوارع مصر يبدا
الاعداد لها قبل هلال الشهر الكريم بايام
حيث يجمع الفتيان في كل حي المال اللازم
لشراء مستلزماتها ثم يتكاتفون في تعليقها
قبيل اذان المغرب ان كنت في الطريق مسافرا
او عائدا من العمل فافطار كم موجود ولو
كنت على الطريق السريع هنا في حي المطريه
شرقي القاهره تشتهر اطول مائده افطار في
مصر في هذه الشوارع الضيقه التي اتسعت
بكرم اهلها يفيض الجميع بالخير في عاده
يتهيا لها ابناء الحي الشعبي البسيط مع
انتصاف الشهر الكريم
لتلتئم الاسر ويحضر الغائب وتتشابك
الموائد لتصير مائده واحده
عنوانها الفرحه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]